Movie fans these days know to keep an eye
out for more than just the plot, as writers
and directors have made a habit of planting
easter eggs, inside jokes, and references
to classic movies at every turn.
But who says the fun has to stop when the
movie ends?
Some of the funniest jokes and hidden treasures
can be found once the credits start to roll.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Details
Hidden in Movie Credits.
Back to the Future
By now, most people know that Marty McFly's
disastrous trip to Old Man Peabody's farm
was the first time he changed the future,
turning "Twin Pines Mall" into "Lone Pine
Mall".
But did you catch the other time travel joke?
The farmer's son only appears for a second,
but is listed in the credits as "Sherman Peabody"
- a reference to Mr Peabody and Sherman, the
stars of the famous time travel cartoon.
Harry Potter & The Prisoner of Azkaban
The Marauder's Map came in handy to help Harry
and his friends track students and teachers
in real time, but the magical map was also
home to the most well-hidden gag in the series.
The movie's credits follow dozens of footprints
throughout the school, including two pairs
that seem to be getting romantic.
Some people claimed it was too adult for a
kids movie, but the animator claims he really
only meant it as a childhood kiss, explaining
the movement.
We'll let you decide.
Robocop
The dark future of Robocop got even darker
when a good cop was slaughtered and rebuilt
as more machine than man, but the homicidal
robots he had to fight were even scarier.
That's what the filmmakers were counting on,
too.
When the final copyright notices scrolled
by in the credits, they packed an added promise:
that ignoring the notices "may result in civil
liability and criminal prosecution by enforcement
droids."
No evidence that they ever made good on the
threat, though.
Frozen
No matter how crazy, unbelievable, or impossible
a movie may be, studios usually cover by warning
audiences that nobody was hurt during filming,
or that incredible stunts were carried out
by professionals.
For Disney's Frozen, the studio decided to
distance itself from a controversial claim
instead, confirming that the outrageous claim
made by Kristoff doesn't represent the opinions
of the studio.
Mission: Impossible 3
Before J.J. Abrams was rebooting Star Trek,
Star Wars, and bringing a new spin to the
Mission: Impossible series, he helped create
the TV sensation LOST.
Knowing how much fans of the TV show loved
a good conspiracy, he made sure to thank The
Hanso Foundation - the company behind the
mysterious DHARMA Project - in the end credits.
Finding Nemo
Fans of Pixar's movies know that the animators
love to plant easter eggs and well-hidden
cameos from other characters - but they're
not always so secretive.
Most young audiences probably left the theater
when the credits on Finding Nemo started rolling,
but if they had stayed put, they would have
caught an unexplained appearance from a swimming
Mike Wazowski, the star of the studio's previous
movie Monsters, Inc.
Pulp Fiction
Quentin Tarantino has shown how strange his
sense of humor can be, so when the victim
of an armed robbery has his line cut short
in the movie's closing act, he didn't miss
a beat.
The actor was supposed to say "I'm just a
coffee shop manager," but was cut off.
The director decided to go with the line he
really did say, crediting the actor as "Coffee
Shop" in the final credits.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Long before CG effects spread across Hollywood,
movies had to rely on actual animals - which
led to a guarantee in the credits that "no
animals were harmed" while making the movie.
Even though they were more fantasy than fact,
the makers of Guardians of the Galaxy still
decided they should let fans know: "no raccoons
or tree creatures were harmed," either.
Fight Club
If you know director David Fincher, then you
know Andrew Kevin Walker, the screenwriter
of both Seven and 8MM.
But Fincher's trusted writer was also brought
in to work on the script for Fight Club.
Even though he didn't do enough work to earn
an official credit for the movie, the director
found a way to include him.
The three police detectives who assault the
movie's narrator are never named, but are
credited as Detective Andrew, Detective Kevin
and Detective Walker, giving the writer a
full, if unusual appearance in the credits.
Brave
The medieval magic of this Pixar story begins
when a young girl can't help but chase after
a will o' the wisp - a magical creature of
blue light.
Their real nature is revealed when the monstrous
bear, Mor-du, is killed, and his true spirit
is released, becoming one of the wisps.
Knowing that, it's hard not to shed a tear
when the final credits dedicate the movie
to the late Steve Jobs, the studio's biggest
supporter, creating a new wisp in his place.
So what do you think of our list?
Have we missed out on any of your favorite
hidden jokes or tributes in movie credits?
Let us know what you think
in the comments, and
remember to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one!